[Applaudissements]
on l'a bien commencé à le voir depuis le
début d'après-midi on n'a pas toujours
des comportements qui sont rationnels
pourquoi on est capable de fumer en
étant médecin pourquoi on est capable de
poursuivre un projet alors que tous les
voyants nous ont indiqué depuis bien
longtemps qu'il fallait l'arrêter
pourquoi on est capable de démarrer un
régime pour finalement manger un cookie
deux heures après c'est du vécu et bien
tout ça moi c'est quelque chose qui me
fascine qui me fascine depuis assez
longtemps depuis j'ai une dizaine
d'années quand ma tante m'a offert un
bouquin qui est d'Olivier Saxe qui
s'appelle l'homme qui prenait sa femme
pour un chapeau et donc c'est surtout un
livre qui parle de la personnalité
humaine de la capacité qu'on a à
s'adapter à son environnement à se
représenter son environnement
et dans ce livre évidemment on parle de
différents patients qui perdent des
fonctions cognitives d'où et dont la
capacité à reconnaître les visages d'où
l'homme qui prenait sa femme pour un
chapeau pourtant qui arrivait à vivre à
peu près normalement juste pour sa femme
que c'était un peu compliqué en tout cas
c'est quelque chose qui moi m'as fasciné
m'a poussé de merde neuroscience et
c'est quelque chose aujourd'hui que je
voudrais partager avec vous sur comment
on prend des décisions et comment
tout simplement à travers quelques
exemples on va essayer d'explorer
comment on construit nos décisions et
comment construire notre représentation
du monde
et donc
on va commencer par un premier exemple
on a tous deux yeux vous voyez cette
image et du coup je vais vous demander
tout simplement que voyez-vous alors on
va pas pouvoir demander tous les avis
dont je vais vous proposais de lever la
main je vais vous dire ce qu'on dirait
d'habitude quand je monte cette image la
première réponse qu'on me donne souvent
et vous lever la main si c'est le cas
c'est un caillou dans un mur qui voit un
caillou dans un mur
on est d'accord tout le monde c'est ce
qui paraît être le plus probable le
caillou dans un mur alors il y a des
gens souvent en formation ils sont un
peu plus créatif on va dire et puis ils
aiment les animaux et ils voient un
popotame ou une souris dans un mur qui
voit l'hippopotame qui est d'humeur
animalière ah j'ai deux trois
hippopotames quand même vous voyez le
petit hippopotame c'est deux yeux c'est
deux narines sa petite bouche on peut
imaginer l'hippopotame vous doutez qu'il
y a un loup vu que je pose la question
donc ceux qui se disent c'est sûrement
pas le caillou ils ont peut-être pas
tort c'est peut-être un hippopotame
dernière proposition qui voit un cigare
dans un mur
là il y a plus personne
personne n'est cubain alors je vais vous
aider à le voir le cigare est là et
pourtant il s'agit bien dans cigare dans
un mur et si je vous remontre cette
image cette fois vous le voyez très bien
le cigare il est là l'image n'a pas
changé vous n'avez pas changé mais par
contre votre perception des choses a
changé l'image n'a pas bougé je n'ai pas
triché je suis bien juste en train de
vous montrer l'image mais par contre
votre perception du monde a complètement
changé tout simplement parce que
première chose que je voulais partager
avec vous nous ne voyons pas la réalité
comme elle est nous la voyons comme nous
sommes et finalement votre cerveau
qu'est ce qu'il va faire chaque seconde
il va prendre des décisions et va
décider de ce qu'il est en train de
percevoir et vu qu'il y a beaucoup de
stimuli en présence et ben il va décider
de ce qui est la réalité la plus
probable pas forcément la réalité on l'a
vu qu'est-ce que la réalité mais ce que
lui perçoit comme étant la réalité la
plus probable c'est ce qu'on appelle de
l'inférence logique il va miser sur ce
qui est le plus probable d'avoir en face
de lui et il est effectivement un peu
plus probable d'avoir un caillou dans un
mur qu'un cigare dans le mur sauf si on
vit à Cuba donc finalement c'est le
choix qui a fait votre cerveau mais il
peut tout à fait changer d'avis et
changer sa décision et percevoir autre
chose
je vous propose d'explorer à nouveau à
travers un deuxième exemple cette fois
je vais vous demander de vous mouiller
un petit peu et décider
selon vous dans le bon sens ça ira mieux
qui vous bat et qui est kiki
c'est un choix tout bête alors qui pense
que Booba est à droite
je pense que c'est Kiki à droite
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
souvent tout le monde donne à peu près
la même réponse en tout cas 98% des
Caucasiens donne la même réponse pour
Booba et à droite et Kiki est à gauche
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que si
je pose la même question
des zimba qui vivent en Namibie qui eux
n'ont pas de langage écrit pour eux les
réponses elles sont totalement
aléatoires il y a plus de raison que
Booba soit à droite que Booba soit à
gauche et nous pourquoi on prend cette
décision tout simplement parce qu'on a
engagé écrit et on a ce qu'on appelle un
symbolisme forme son qu'on apprend
depuis qu'on est petit et donc ça nous
paraît que Booba soit plutôt quelque
chose de ça ressemble plus à un B
quelque chose d'un peu plus rond et que
Kiki plus piquant d'un peu plus strident
par le son c'est une représentation
qu'on sait créer et finalement qui n'a
aucune réalité mais n'empêche qu'on
prend tous cette même décision notre
cerveau nous aide à prendre cette
décision donc la deuxième chose que je
veux partager avec vous c'est qu'on va
prendre à chaque instant plein de micros
décisions qui vont être basés sur nos
croyances
ça va y arriver nos représentations qui
sont implicites on en a pas forcément
conscience notre expérience et notre
culture et c'est ça qui va conditionner
la façon dont on prend des décisions et
on l'a vu on en prend des milliers de
décisions voilà on trouvera plusieurs le
chiffre de 35000 revient beaucoup on est
tous les scientifiques sont pas d'accord
sur la question mais en tout cas c'est
des milliers
70350000 on trouve plusieurs chiffres
mais c'est des milliers de décisions
qu'on prend par jour et on l'a vu
également annonçant on l'a pas vu
227,226,7 décisions par jour sont prises
juste à propos de la nourriture donc
c'est beaucoup plus que l'histoire de
mon cookie
et on l'a vu 99% de nos décisions sont
totalement inconscientes
et notre cerveau va les prendre pour
nous pour nous aider à prendre et
apprendre à faire face à tous les
stimuli auxquels il doit faire face
durant une au cours d'une journée
donc moi la question que je me suis
rapidement posée c'est finalement quelle
place pour la rationalité finalement
aujourd'hui tout le monde nous dit on
est absolument pas rationnel on bascule
même dans une théorie qui est
complètement posée l'homme serait
complètement irrationnel guidé par ses
instincts manipulables à souhait et il
serait uniquement une boule d'émotion
qui répond à tout ce qui bouge par voilà
en réagissant de venir un peu un peu
rapide donc moi c'est une question que
je vous ouvre et que je vous pose quelle
est la place qu'on peut le laisser à la
rationalité et ce qu'on peut vraiment
reprendre le contrôle de nos décisions
effectivement
l'évaluation émotionnelle c'est à dire
la réaction émotionnelle en stimuli elle
va se faire en 200 millisecondes et
c'est elle va se faire deux fois plus
rapidement que l'évaluation cognitive
c'est-à-dire qu'on va sauter bondir sur
une chaise en voyant l'araignée qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure avant même de dire il
est absolument pas dangereuse qu'elle va
rien faire ou même que pire c'était
absolument pas une araignée c'était
juste une petite poussière qui sortait
c'est la première réaction instinctive
qui va nous permettre de survivre et
c'est la première réaction que l'on va
faire la première réaction qu'on va
avoir notre environnement et donc
effectivement nos émotions c'est la
première clé d'entrée qu'on a sur sur le
monde elles vont guider nos décisions et
nos actions est-ce que pour autant on
est complètement irrationnel moi c'est
une question que je vous pose est-ce que
vraiment quel est l'objectif de notre
cerveau il doit prendre 35000 décisions
par jour quel est son objectif est-ce
que son objectif c'est d'être rationnel
le cerveau il est absolument pas fait
pour produire des comportements
rationnels vous l'avez compris il est
fait pour s'adapter rapidement à la
réalité ce qui veut c'est survivre parce
qu'après tout vaut mieux fuir en voyant
un chat qu'on a pris pour un tigre que
de se faire dévorer et donc il a appris
à fonctionner comme ça depuis des
milliers d'années depuis lui si jusqu'à
l'homo sapiens ce qu'on est aujourd'hui
de prendre des décisions rapidement
quitte à s'éloigner un tout petit peu de
la logique ou de la rationalité et donc
ça pour ça il se base sur un système je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails mais
qui s'appelle le système 1 c'est un
système de penser qui nous permet de
prendre des décisions extrêmement
rapidement des décisions instinctives
pour justement la survie et des
décisions des automatismes des
automatismes qu'on développe avec
l'expérience plus on va faire face à des
expériences plus on va apprendre à créer
des traces dans la neige c'est à dire
que quand on est enfant on arrive on a
une piste vierge et on peut créer toutes
les traces qu'on veut et puis ensuite en
grandissant apprendre on va créer des
traces et on va emprunter souvent le
même chemin et cette race vont nous pose
vont nous permettre d'avoir des
justement automatique c'est à dire que
face à une situation de savoir plus
rapidement quelle est la décision qu'il
faut prendre pour justement agir plus
vite parce que l'objectif du cerveau il
est bien là cette perle moins d'effort
possible pour prendre des décisions
parce qu'il en a 35000 à prendre dans la
journée et de les prendre le plus
rapidement possible et c'est bien là son
seul objectif mais son objectif on a
quand même dit c'est d'être de prendre
des décisions qui sont adaptées à la
réalité donc le but c'est de prendre des
décisions qui lui permettre d'agir dans
cette réalité et de temps en temps et
ben ces automatismes ils vont conduire à
pardon à faire des erreurs de jugement
ou des erreurs d'interprétation de
commettre des erreurs dans leur décision
et ça c'est ce qu'on appelle des biais
cognitifs c'est bien finalement c'est un
petit peu le pendant négatif de nos
automatismes les automatismes ils sont
là pour nous aider ils sont là pour
notre bien mais dans de temps en temps
il nous conduisent à faire un peu vite
et à commettre des erreurs donc c'est un
peu un paradoxe de nos de notre réalité
de la logique au détriment de la réalité
et bien ça va être la sortie de piste ça
va être on a pris la décision trop
rapidement on a sauté à la conclusion
avant même de se poser la bonne question
et donc souvent la solution qui est
proposée par notre cerveau la plus
rapide la plus instinctive la plus
adaptée à la situation qu'on est en
train de vivre c'est pas forcément la
plus logique des décisions et ça ça
s'appelle c'est un biais qui s'appelle
le rasoir de Cam mais des billets comme
ça on en a plus de 250
donc la thématique d'aujourd'hui c'était
qui contrôle et donc la thématique moi
que je voulais aborder avec vous c'est
est-ce qu'il est possible de reprendre
le contrôle de nos décisions est-ce que
c'est complètement utopique il y a une
réalité là-dedans
on l'a vu 4% de décisions sont
inconscientes donc on vous on va me dire
impossible vaut mieux lâcher prise c'est
vrai
mais on va voir également qu'on peut
essayer d'adapter l'environnement pour
essayer non pas de contrôler nos
décisions mais de prendre de meilleures
décisions on pourra jamais toutes les
contrôler on en prend 35000 dans la
journée et la plupart elles sont
justement faites pour qu'on puisse se
concentrer sur les bonnes les décisions
importantes et le reste il vaut mieux
lâcher prise et ne pas contrôler ce
qu'on se surprend n'a pas d'influence
mais on va essayer de voir ensemble
est-ce qu'on peut quand même essayer de
prendre de meilleures décisions
alors déjà on va se poser une question
qu'est-ce qu'une décision c'est quoi une
décision une décision c'est juste un
pari c'est votre cerveau qui va comparer
ce qu'il est en train de vivre à ce
qu'il a déjà vécu et qui va essayer
d'anticiper prédire sur le résultat en
disant si je réagis comme ça ça devrait
bien se passer ça devrait être adapté et
donc il ne fait après tout
un pari basé sur quoi en fait dans notre
environnement notre environnement il est
riche il est mouvant il se passe plein
de choses on a de plus en plus de
stimulation en plus on a tout un tas de
stimuli qui vont arriver dans notre
environnement ça on peut pas les
contrôler on peut pas savoir ce qui nous
est arrivé on peut pas contrôler notre
environnement et vaut mieux pas essayer
de le faire parce que c'est tenter le
contrôle absolu c'est complètement vain
donc vaut mieux pas essayer de contrôler
par contre le but de notre cerveau ça va
être de produire des réactions adaptées
à la réalité donc notre réaction et
notre décision elle va être adaptée un
contexte si je vois le chat dans mon
salon je risque de moins paniquer que si
je le vois en plein milieu de la jungle
et il va être adapté à l'humain qui
prend la décision l'humain qui a ses
propres expériences ses propres
croyances ses propres automatismes ce
qu'on appelle des modèles mentaux
et ses propres modèles mentaux vont
conditionner la façon dont on réfléchit
et dont on décide et donc si on ne peut
pas contrôler la décision elle-même en
tous les cas notre décision va être très
rapide souvent instinctive souvent
inconsciente
99,74 % du temps inconsciente on peut
quand même essayer de transformer le
contexte et l'environnement dans lequel
on va l'apprendre pour essayer de
l'influencer alors si je reviens en
exemple de mon cookie parce que je me
suis beaucoup creusée la question et la
tête sur la question je sais que quand
je suis face à un cookie et que j'ai
faim je vais avoir tendance à vouloir le
manger ça je peux pas je peux pas lutter
contre par contre ce que je peux faire
c'est décider de changer le contexte ce
que je peux essayer de faire c'est de ne
jamais aller faire les courses l'estomac
vide parce que je sais comme ça
j'arriverai à peu mieux contrôler mes
pulsions ce que je peux faire c'est
faire une liste de courses hyper à tête
reposée à froid je fais ma liste et je
devais acheter que ce dont j'ai besoin
pour être sûr de ne pas avoir le cookie
dans le placard je pourrais pas essayer
ce que je peux faire c'est trouver des
alternatives c'est à dire essayer de
mettre au fourneau et de trouver des
recettes de cookies qui sont un peu plus
assis qui me permettent de me faire
plaisir tout en respectant on sait de
toute façon que le cerveau va essayer de
prendre des décisions les plus rapides
et celles qui vont demander de faire le
moins d'effort donc pour ça on peut
essayer de l'aider en contraignant le
contexte et en ritualisant et
automatisant certaines décisions des
petites décisions qui sont pas très
importantes parce qu'on l'a vu quand on
doit prendre trop de décisions si à
chaque décision devait pondérer le pour
le contre finalement on ferait plus rien
du tout on serait complètement inhibé à
se dire finalement je fais plus rien de
peur de mal faire donc finalement vaut
mieux essayer de ritualiser
d'automatiser certaines petites
décisions pour essayer de pouvoir
contrôler certaines grosses décisions
qui auront des impacts parce que
justement on n'aura pas cette fatigue
décisionnelle on aura encore de
l'énergie mentale pour aller se poser
les bonnes questions sur les grandes
décisions
et donc ça transformer le contexte on
peut le faire de plein de façons on peut
le faire comme je disais en ritualisant
donc les rituels ça peut être moi je
sais que je coupe mon ordinateur à
certaines heures de la journée pour être
sûr de ne pas avoir de notification pas
être dérangé et être justement concentré
sur ce que je suis en train de faire ce
qu'on peut faire c'est décider je
n'emmène pas mon ordinateur pendant les
vacances je ne prends uniquement un
bouquin comme ça je suis sûr que je vais
pouvoir me déconnecter
ou avoir de la méthode c'est à dire je
vais prendre une checklist décisionnel
quand je veux décider par exemple pour
des choses qui ont des forces enjeux un
entretien d'embaume quelque chose je
vais aller mettre tous les critères de
décision qui sont importants pour moi et
je vais être sûr de répondre à toute
cette check-list et de ne pas prendre la
décision basée sur mes instincts ou en
tout cas de repousser un maximum mon
intuition et de me servir de mes
émotions comme un guide et donc comme
seule réponse qui est produite par mon
système décisionnel
ou dernière solution je peux faire appel
aux collectif ce qu'on appelle la
sagesse des foules je peux décider que
quand il y a des décisions importantes
je ne les prends pas seuls et que je
vais essayer de recueillir un maximum
d'avis un maximum de points de vue
justement pour essayer de limiter un
petit peu mes pieds
deuxième chose on peut du coup essayer
d'influencer le contexte pour
contraindre nos décisions en tout cas
aider notre système décisionnel à
prendre de meilleures décisions deuxième
chose sur laquelle on va pouvoir agir
c'est l'humain là vous me voyez venir
c'est clairement pas ce qu'il y a de
plus évident mais pourtant
celui qui est le maître de lui-même et
plus grand que celui qui est le maître
du monde effectivement reprendre le
contrôle de apprendre à penser autrement
ça va demander beaucoup d'efforts parce
qu'il va apprendre il va falloir
apprendre à résister à ces automatismes
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on a un
système 1 qui nous permet de réagir très
rapidement de nous adapter à la réalité
mais on a également un deuxième système
ce deuxième système c'est s'appelle le
système de original et ce deuxième
système lui il est plus long plus
réfléchi et il nous permet de prendre
des décisions éclairées je vous ai dit
on va dire rationnel on a vu que la
rationalité c'était pas fait pour
l'humain mais en tout cas des meilleurs
décisions des décisions éclairées et
donc tout l'enjeu il va être où l'enjeu
il va être d'essayer de résister à nos
automatismes de résister à notre système
1 pour laisser le temps à notre deuxième
système le système de d'agir et ça la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y a un
troisième système magique qui s'appelle
le système 3
et ce système 3 lui il va inhiber le
système 1 et permet au système de
laisser tant d'agir et quand est-ce
qu'il va faire ça on a dit que le but de
notre cerveau c'était quoi prendre des
décisions adaptées à la réalité donc
notre système il va proposer une
solution très rapide qui semble adapter
à la réalité c'est ce qu'on appelle la
présomption de rationalité et puis dans
certains cas votre cerveau il va voir la
solution proposée rapidement puis il va
avoir un doute dire ça veut pas dire
d'être la meilleure des décennies de la
manière des solutions celle-là et du
coup on va inhiber première réponse qui
est rapide et on va essayer d'avoir le
faire agir notre système de pour avoir
le temps de réfléchir et de pondérer la
décision et ben c'est ce qui va falloir
faire finalement la meilleure arme pour
reprendre le contrôle de vos décisions
ça va être d'éveiller son esprit
critique et de cultiver le doute
justement laissez faire naître le petit
doute comme on l'a fait aujourd'hui à se
dire elle nous montait un caillou dans
un humain il doit y avoir un look dans
cette histoire éveillez le doute pour
justement se laisser le temps
contraire d'aller voir d'autres points
de vue d'aller se questionner les a
priori les postulats qui y sont la base
de votre réflexion se dire je déciderai
comme ça moi je serais bien ça mais
peut-être que c'est pas la meilleure des
solutions
et donc s'entraîner à résister et donc
la meilleure chose que vous pouvez faire
c'est développer votre esprit critique
et comme on l'a déjà vu considérer qui
va une réalité mais des réalités
je vais juste du coup vous tester pour
voir si vous avez compris cette capacité
à résister à vos automatismes et à aimer
votre esprit critique avec un exemple et
vous allez me dire si c'est une info ou
une entorse la Suisse a le plus grand
nombre de prix Nobel par habitant
la Suisse a aussi la plus forte
consommation de chocolat par habitant
donc conclusion manger du chocolat
devenir prix Nobel est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est une info qui est issue
d'un vrai article scientifique ou que
c'est une intox
un levez la main
tout le monde pense que c'est faux et ma
figurer
un article qui a été publié en 2012 un
article scientifique dans un journal en
plus en journée un bon journal qui a
publié cette corrélation et en fait
eux-mêmes les scientifiques eux-mêmes
ont été biaisés évidemment c'est faux
j'ai essayé de manger du chocolat j'ai
pas encore eu le prix Nobel et ils ont
fait face à ce qu'on appelle l'illusion
de corrélation c'est à dire une
corrélation tellement forte qu'ils
étaient persuadés qu'elle était
forcément réelle mais c'est croire en la
causalité de deux événements qui en fait
absolument qui ne sont absolument pas
liées tout ça pour vous dire que même
quand on essaie de lutter contre ces
biais finalement c'est pas toujours
évident de résister et que ça arrive
finalement à tout le monde donc ma
conclusion et je m'arrêterai là si vous
deviez retenir une seule chose de mon
intervention c'est éveiller votre esprit
critique cultiver le doute essayez
d'éveiller votre curiosité un maximum
pour essayer de résister à votre
automatisme et puis surtout de
considérer d'autres prismes de point de
vue et si de temps en temps comme
Olivier Saxe ça doit vous pousser à
considérer votre femme et à prendre
votre femme pour un chapeau et ben
finalement c'est peut-être un pas de
côté qui va vous permettre de comprendre
de brillante décision merci beaucoup